- there's a weight-shift you said is the
weight shift I step into that
[Music]
so this way I'll be ahead of her on the
skywars so when she turns right I'm back
you see she turns and then she turns a
nice step I'm not inside I'm going all
the way around
this is actually I just keep going
she's going around me but if my tank on
here
I made the same relationship you see
she's gonna turn - I don't want to take
from here then open up my let's have fun
here then if she steps I was going there
[Music]
okay
here you see I mean I'm behind him not
on the side of him not in front they
come back here so if he gets up you see
behind him so I start here looks like
you're behind him buddy who gets up I'm
not behind him GC and then obviously
this one I'm not okay so we fight from
that corner this way see that would be
the last time he got up and I came this
way okay this time I'm here I go the
other way
[Music]
but the Kazushi is not a goes here and
then I pivot his head there there's a oh
wait so let's say I'm gonna turn his
head I want you to throw underneath
underneath
[Music]
we're gonna go slow so you see that
you're trying to push them don't see
that okay so you tried don't put your
hand on the floor if all you get isn't
it so you understand it go here Hey
yes okay here we go
can you do it yes do you see
so I'm not tilting him when you go
standing you get weird accent any people
who don't know the gymnastics his from
here is Blanco
okay so again we're just changing our
ideas
just change the relationship
[Music]
the time to practice exactly
you
you get it